i was failing that was the point for me
where i was like
i need to do things differently
the hardest thing i've ever done
it's james smith great talking personal
trainer he's helping you get confident
some see james's curse-filled rant says
confrontational oh james got me a
narcissist
james good to see you again
self-esteem and confidence is decaying
when you're at that place of feeling
that you don't have enough confidence
it's actually a crossroads it's a left
and a right action and inaction whatever
you're not changing you're choosing
dating is such a big topic because
people either don't have the confidence
required to meet someone or they might
not have the confidence to leave someone
we're allowed to be ignorant of these
things and we're allowed to be wrong but
it doesn't mean we shouldn't endeavor to
get the best possible outcome
what are you not confident about i
constantly have these battles in my head
why did i create this fast why did i
have sweat patches from such a simple
interaction of being uncomfortable i
have the same insecurities the same
fears feelings of inadequacies
sometimes my biggest fear is
losing is not the same as being defeated
you have to be audacious you have to put
your head above the power pit i'm sure
i'm going to be absolutely slammed
saying this
so without further ado
i'm stephen butler and this is the diary
of a ceo i hope nobody's listening but
if you are then please keep this
yourself
[Music]
james good to see you again thank you
very much for having me back it's uh
it's i gotta say we don't have many
guests back but um our conversation was
so
inspiring and
surprising to me
when i messaged you the other day and
said if you're ever back in london i'd
love to have you back on and then i
learned you'd written a book about
confidence
why did you write a book about
confidence
well
it's kind of interesting that through my
entire career i've
learned something personally and then
i've
you know taught other people kind of the
processes so the first book not a diet
book i went through years of fitness
industry [ __ ] we spoke about before
and kind of by the end of it through my
own journeys i was like i could teach
people about this and i didn't want to
write a diet book system i was like
let's you know break down everything put
it into a book then the second book
offer i was like i can't do another one
if i'd written a second book about
fitness it would have said a lot about
the first you know when people do
sequels things i'm like oh you must have
done a great job
and i kind of realized by accident that
my work-life balance was pretty good
and wrote the second book a lot of the
things we spoke about in that last
podcast were based off not a life coach
now
the kind of strange thing that i say to
people is i'm not a very confident
person
i have the same
insecurities the same fears the same
feelings of inadequacies as the majority
of people but i kind of have a
set of values and a way that i see these
problems where i can break them down and
dismantle them and
in the book in the first chapter i say
a lot of people sit back and they think
other people are confident as if it's a
trait like height or
people said it's a superpower but
straight away i actually typed that in
the first part of the book i was like
confidence is a superpower but then
superpowers aren't accomplishable by
mortals it's almost something out of
your reach
and i'm a big believer that confidence
can be within people's reach and
even chatting to people in the same
profession they have a problem or a fear
of judgment of whatever it is and
if i spend five minutes with that person
i can motivate them to
post on social media to
prospect more with their business
whatever it is and i've realized it's
not something people are lacking it's
more so the way they perceive and view
their reality
what are you not confident about people
i think would be surprised to hear that
you have insecurities and inadequacies
and there's things you're not confident
about everything body image which is why
i ended up going down the first
huge
10 years of my life with not a diet book
i was overweight as a kid
even now i constantly have these battles
in my head through
how should i look what should i be doing
shall i be dieting and i think that's
why a lot of people resonate with what i
say because a lot of what i say to them
is also for myself
a lot of
you know i say to people that i know
this is how you're feeling so that's how
i feel myself
and
it's it's an interesting one even with
dating with professional life some of
them i feel like i kind of got lucky i'm
not a massive believer in luck i kind of
tripped over some of the steps to
becoming confident and
even working in door-to-door sales where
working for npower in gloucester
knocking on hundreds of doors a day
it allowed me to perceive issues in
front of me as a numbers game and then
at the average of knocking on 100 to
make a sale suddenly things didn't seem
so daunting and people go oh you need to
be really confident to knock on doors
for a living i was like well not so much
if you appreciate there's a certain
amount of times you need to do something
before you experience success it's not
so scary
email marketing
i knew email marketing would work i sent
emails every day for 10 months no one
bought in 10 months someone bought
finally so it was an appreciation of the
numbers social media
four and a half years i posted near
about every day before
i made any money from it things
aren't so much scary or to be feared
it's how you look at those things in
front of you that really kind of
break down the fear because we're all
capable of doing things but we like to
almost push things further away than we
can reach so that it gives us a reason
not to do it one thing that really blew
my mind
is i had
liver king on the podcast right
this is a man for anybody that doesn't
know him who is
jacked he walks around with us with his
top off
um he's very you know direct and loud
and apparently confident
but at the very end of the conversation
i asked him to tell me something he's
never told anyone before
and what he said blew my mind he said
coming on this podcast today and
speaking in front of people cripples me
to the point that i can't sleep and then
he tells me that between the age of 10
and 14 years old he was bullied
horrifically beaten up every day had no
friends and i i was trying to put the
pieces together that
um
and you kind of allude to it at the
start of your book when you start
talking about the different types of
confidence that he might be confident in
some ways but
the
social confidence was literally knocked
out of him at 10 years old so in social
situations where there's a chance of
rejection from the crowd which is what
happened to him in school he is still
crippled to this day it appears to me
that
there's a real variance in people's um
social confidence which is originates
from their like early
self-story
and really that early self story i'm
trying to understand how much of that
determines
our confidence today because there's
tricks and tips and the five second rule
and all this stuff but if how do we
really have to go back and fix that [ __ ]
that happened to us at 10 years old on
the playground no i don't think so and
that's kind of the important thing i
don't think it's like a trauma that we
need to hold dearly to ourselves but
like you say so for instance if you were
to say james says 3000 people out there
need you to perform a talk with no
preparation i'd like cool but if you
would say hey there's a girl at the bar
and i need you to go approach her on a
friday night and try and get a number
that would be like that's that's scary
to me so it's it's kind of like double
standards like you say some situations
everyone has a certain lacking type of
confidence even the most confident of
people and
that could be because when i was 12 the
first girl asked out said no it could be
that or it could be because i've done
more talks and i think that
at the root core of everything is is a
form of repetition and
people that aren't confident to do
things
they need to find
something they have the level of courage
to do and get to that point and for
instance that's something i don't need
to work on and as i'm in a relationship
i probably shouldn't be working on this
either but if i i'm petrified of talking
to a girl or or a guy from any women
listening or either either for whoever's
this thing
maybe i don't have the courage to ask
for the number but i might have the
courage to go say hello or to compliment
them or to you know do something
chivalrous and if people can then do
that
then maybe from there they can move on
and i think
is one of those things where everyone
has like a gaping hole in their
confidence and for liver king it's an
interesting one at first i was actually
very anti-him because he is obnoxious he
actually has a very similar approach to
what i do like in your face this is what
i believe in if you don't believe in it
that's cool
but
i can sometimes look at him and
appreciate that a lot of people
are not being who they are they're being
who they need to be and i feel i
resonate with that side of him where as
i'm sure you realize on social media i'm
very much like listen mate you know do
this calorie deficit you know [ __ ] off
all of that but really i'm not like that
i portray the person i need to be
it's one of those things where a lot of
the time people need to appreciate that
maybe everyone around them is fearful of
everything like you but they're more
focused about being who they need to be
not worrying about who they are
in the the start of this book in chapter
one you you investigate this idea of
pain points as it relates to confidence
what do you mean by pain points so we
could look at this in the form of sales
as well so i cannot sell to someone
unless i understand their pain points
and i use an analogy that probably is
the one i've had most experience with
with people in the gym they come they
sit down hi james i want to get fitter i
want to lose a bit of weight i want to
tone up and i'm like that's not really
what you want that's not a pain point
that is
a knee-jerk reaction to what you think i
want to hear
when you delve a bit deeper they go up
my husband stop [ __ ] me you know
every time i stand up in a meeting i've
got to pull my top down over the layers
of flap that i have
i don't feel confident in areas of my
life that i should because i'm so
crippled by the confidence i have with
my physique
i'm not taken seriously the pain points
are deep and people need to draw on
those because
the day that you're getting out of bed
and you feel like [ __ ] and you're tired
and you want to give up
i want to be toned isn't going to do it
the fact that your real pain point is
that you're lonely and you're getting
older and you're worrying about the fact
you might not find a compatible
companion ever
that is a strong enough pain point for
you to change
being more toned isn't so
interestingly for some you know i know
people that are in that exact same
situation
and i've debated for many a year whether
someone's you know the situation you
described that i'm getting older i'm
lonely i'm scared i'll be alone forever
i know people in that exact exact same
situation that are exhibiting the fear
of the consequences of a life lifelong
loneliness
but they still don't do anything about
it
is there such thing as like wanting to
want to be someone
is it i'm not sure to answer your
question but
one of the things i would say to that
person is
you're in the and i'm only using this an
example i think dating is an analogy i
love to use i actually use it when i
talk about business talks i say
marketing is like dating you know and
we won't get down that too much but you
look at the person at the bar you you
feel the fear
rather than counting down from five five
four three two one oh my god i've got
the confidence let me go talk to them
they could instead just for a flash of a
moment just think to themselves i'm
lonely i don't want to be lonely what
out of these two things is more
uncomfortable for me the idea of going
another week another month being single
or the idea of talking to a stranger and
surely when you add and level those two
things up the pain point of being lonely
should be much worse than the pain point
of talking to a stranger
if you feel undervalued at work the idea
of talking to your boss and expressing
how you feel that's a pain point you're
like you know that's going to make me
feel uncomfortable
but then the pain point of feeling
undervalued and not being given the
bonus you were promised a year ago you
level them up and you're like there's
always
two directions in which you can go and
you've tweeted and mentioned this before
you say saying nothing is still saying
something
doing nothing is still doing something
and
they also say whatever you're not
changing you're choosing
and these are really important because
that person and again
same analogy whatever it is when you're
at that place of feeling that you don't
have enough confidence it's
actually a crossroads it's a left and a
right it's a dichotomy of action and
inaction
and if you
are controlled by fear and you don't
muster the courage to do what you need
to do especially by using the pain
points to motivate yourself you are
choosing an action by doing nothing that
is a choice
and
people just seem to think that you know
not starting the passion project not
posting or s
expressing something on social media
they seem to think if they do nothing
that it's a void in our reality but it's
not it's still a choice of an action i
used to think of like people ask me
about confidence a lot and it's taken me
quite some time to develop my thoughts
on it because you know when you i think
level one of the confidence
um
[Music]
self-help guru is like
look yourself in the mirror and tell
yourself you love yourself like that's
like step one and then eventually
hopefully your thinking progresses when
you find the holes in that thinking and
then i arrived at the conclusion that
confidence
as we kind of
like say it talk about it in culture i
know there's multiple definitions and
lots of nuance but confidence as we
describe it in culture is really just
um is based on the evidence you have in
yourself like all beliefs are based on
evidence-based subjective correct or
incorrect evidence
and
therefore if it is evidence-based
the only way to build your confidence is
to go and get evidence
um
and i say this because there's a lot
there's a narrative that you can just
kind of like write down in your book or
or look yourself in the mirror and say
i'm gonna be confident i'm gonna be sexy
i'm gonna be a millionaire which i don't
think is
factually supported by how other beliefs
work
so confidence so when i started writing
the book i wasn't sat there like i know
everything about confidence i was sat
there going
i couldn't answer if you were to say
james what is confidence when i start
writing it again i don't know so that's
why i was so excited about writing it
but one of the
interesting kind of
ways that i wrote about it in one of the
points was if you imagine confidence on
a spectrum with anxiety on one end and
confidence on the other
anxiety is predicting failure and
confidence is predicting success
and
that is a really important thing to
think about because
our expectations
massively influence the outcome of
things and like you say there if people
just go into a room and go i'm you know
i'm amazing i'm whatever it's not really
going to work
even as one of your previous guests said
about interrogative self-talk asking
yourself questions is a more positive
thing
instead of saying i can do this podcast
today and do well
i asked myself can you do well on this
podcast today me answer oh do you know
what i did all right in the last one it
got a lot of downloads so it is one of
those things that is in so many
different spectrums and it has so many
different meanings but
a lot of it points towards predicting
success in things and even if you don't
have the evidence to predict success
we should be able to be wrong
if there's something i want to
accomplish
i can't let my mind and my thoughts take
over i must in some sense be
overconfident and predict success but if
i'm wrong that's fine but what i can't
do is just set
every single
default to being this isn't going to
work because
if you don't think something's going to
work you're already tripped at the first
hurdle and
there's a guy david robinson written a
book called the expectation effect
and in that book
they
got a group of people i can't remember
how big their study was but they lied to
them and said this group have got a gene
that is going to hinder their turnover
of oxygen and this group over here
doesn't they got them to perform fitness
tests and the people that were told they
had this gene mutation performed a lot
better the other people who didn't and
even just being primed with a lie
completely changed their output in a
fitness test so
schools don't teach confidence society
doesn't really breed confidence because
although on one hand confidence is
essential for innovation if we don't
have confident people you know elon musk
he was confident enough to say that
rocket we could land it back on earth
and you would know you know you're crazy
but
society doesn't care if you're confident
or not society doesn't care if you talk
to that person or not society doesn't
care if you get a pay rise no one in the
world is going to come along and care
about your levels of confidence it's
something we need to do ourselves on in
that example of them priming to you know
there's being two groups and they tell
one of them a lie and then the one that
believes that they have a genetic
advantage performed better right yeah so
is is that not the case then for lying
to yourself
so fake it to you make it
i don't particularly like that
terminology in in the book i write about
it because
what's your what's your metric of
success in that to fake it until you get
recognition for something
i think
with that and with the book and with
expectations you've got manifestation
and the placebo effect and they're
intertwined but they're both separate so
manifestation i think is a very
dangerous thing where people think i'm
just going to think about success you
know i'm going to meditate about success
i'm going to get it
but then things like the placebo effect
is also a powerful thing
sham surgeries that were performed on
people they would be cut open they would
do nothing they'd stitch them back up
and up to 50 of people reported feeling
better that's crazy when people take
or 30 people that took the vaccine in
the trials that were given the
no vaccine felt ill afterwards because
they thought they were going to feel ill
i've seen as well i didn't put this on
the book so i couldn't find the study
the size of the pill you take as a
painkiller even with placebos can impact
the levels of pain that people
you know report disappearing so although
we can't say you know i just you know
pretend you're going to be confident
pretend all of this in the same sense we
do need to instill a level of belief in
ourselves that we are able to accomplish
stuff and
if we try
and we falsify that optimism and it
doesn't work out we create another
building block to step on and
behind everyone who's an expert in
anything there is a level of mastery and
failure is put in such a negative light
in society but failure is the
most cases the pathway to development so
even if we do
you know point the dial towards optimism
if things don't go right that's fine
we're allowed to be wrong we're allowed
to make mistakes you're allowed to try
that endeavor that you want and for it
to all [ __ ] up i think that i was just
thinking about that then the i guess the
difference is with the placebo effect
you don't know that it's a lie whereas
if i look to myself in the mirror and
said you are in fact jesus christ i
would know that that was a lie and so
placebo i guess you know the placebo
effects stuff can work and even in that
operation they didn't know they were
being lied to in that in those two
control groups where one of them
believed they had a genetic advantage
they thought it was true the problem is
we can't actually lie to ourselves and
the the example i always give sometimes
when i speak about confidence on stage
is like if i had your mom in a headlock
and i was pointing a gun at her and i
said you have to believe i'm jesus when
she dies everything's on the line and
all you could do is pretend you couldn't
actually believe i was jesus if
everything was on the line you could
only and so
that for me was the clearest
evidence i needed that i can never
really lie to myself about who i am
it doesn't have to be a liars it could
be even just a change in narrative
so
i remember so many times throughout my
life just before i was about to go on a
date with a stranger which i found
incredibly daunting it's one of the
reasons i drank on dates for
the first 25 years of my life
but that voice in your head you don't
have to lie to yourself but the voice in
your head goes what if this is the worst
day i'll ever go on
but all you need to do is change that to
say what if this is the best day i'll
ever go on that's all i'm saying
and
that is a change in expectations it's a
different change in thought it's a
different perspective on your reality
that's upcoming i don't think we should
ever lie to ourselves but we should at
least turn the dial towards optimism
because
we are
inherently
pessimistic with our with our biases
audacity you talk about that being one
of the most important things um
you describe it as being at the
forefront of any of the successes you've
experienced in your life what is
audacity and how do you define that and
what role is it played for you i had a
lot of opinions in the fitness industry
but by airing them you open yourself up
to a lot of criticism you open yourself
up to hatred
five years ago i don't think anyone bar
a couple of my girlfriends hated me all
right you know no one now there are
thousands thousands of people
because you have to be audacious you
have to put your head above the power
pit to really you know put yourself
forward even as we said before with this
podcast
you had to be audacious one day as
someone who'd never done a podcast to go
we're going to do a podcast in here and
you you had to sit there and believe for
a second we're going to make this the
uk's leading podcast
and in some respects
behind anyone's
level of success there was an audacious
endeavor at the beginning
whether it was to do a podcast whether
it was to start a business whatever it
was and i think that
that's again something that's not fully
bred into people you know or someone has
an idea you know go put that idea out
there be audacious with it you know
don't be afraid to be wrong don't be
afraid of critics and
ultimately for me
something that i kind of understood was
there are going to be a lot of people
that are never going to be interested in
what you're doing and they're never
going to be interested in
a book that i release or whatever i
can't take their criticisms to heart
and fully understanding that
there are people out there that are
going to dislike me but i can't worry
too much about that because they're
never going to benefit my net equation
they're never going to come to a talk or
buy a book or anything like that
so audaciousness is like a
an essential element for progress in
this but you need to be armed with
understanding that you're going to be
haters that there are going to be people
that are going to
not like what you say or what you do and
there's quite literally no one out there
that doesn't get criticized for
something so audaciousness does have
that dark side to it but
for people again
being audacious with your endeavor what
if it's the worst thing you ever do then
again what if it's the best thing you
ever do
since you came on this podcast last time
i've been asking guests a similar
question which which is about this in
ingredients list of happiness have you
ever heard me say this to anybody i've
heard you say it but okay
just won't just ask that just in case
you had a premeditated response but the
question i ask people is um if happiness
was a list of ingredients
on a
on a recipe um in different weights and
quantities what is missing from your
list of ingredients that would make you
perfectly happy oh john i haven't
thought about this i haven't thought
about this at all
i don't really look at my life and go
what's missing and even
some things i could say was oh you know
a permanent visa for australia
but i quite like the fact it's not
happened yet i'm looking forward to it
if it does come and even if i don't get
residency in australia i kind of relish
the challenge of what i would have to do
to then get it again so all of the
things that are lacking from my life
also seem like little challenges that
i'm excited for
but honestly i know a lot of people have
a facade for happiness
i'm progressing in everything that i'm
doing and as i said before even on the
back burner i love jiu jitsu i'm
competing a bit at the moment i teach
classes
on a friday evening i have that and
so much of my values does revolve around
my work the book doing well my
professional life but then also at the
back burner i've always said this that i
could just get a dog
open a little jiu jitsu dojo with my
savings put it near the beach somewhere
hopefully in australia and i could just
teach people jiu jitsu for the rest of
my life and i look at that and i go
on some days that's better than my
existing life you know so it's one of
those things where i don't really dwell
or use any mental or cognitive ability
thinking about
what's missing i don't think that's a
productive way to use cognitive effort
i think i am i sometimes question the
balance of things in my life and i
i sometimes i wonder whether it's
society telling me that i that the
balance is wrong or whether it's you
know your girlfriend telling you the
balance is wrong it happens a lot
um or whether it's you know something
else but i think more in terms of the
balance of things so for example i might
be going to the gym too much or i might
be
working too much or i might not be
working enough
and those are the kind of things that i
i think i spend some time thinking about
usually upon getting feedback
i foolishly
for a long time used to say that i was
fortunate that i'd never struggled with
mental health problems and in some
respects that's true because there is a
bit of a throw that dice with how you
know our baselines of certain hormones
or whatever in this trauma that can
occur in people's lives
but a friend of mine who suffered with
depression quite heavily he said to me
you are not aware of your habits that
protect your mental health and you need
to go away and think about the things
you're doing to actually
you know uphold this because
the way i see mental health now and this
could be quite controversial is like a
table like the one in front of us with
many legs and the legs can be completely
subjective am i going outside enough are
my family relationships good enough
how's my professional life how's my bank
account whatever it is
and you can kick away one of the legs
and you'll be okay but people if they
don't realize that legs from the table
are disappearing it only takes that one
final kick before it topples over for me
being comfortable
not working too hard not traveling too
much not stretching myself too thin
is something that is really important to
me and
i haven't
drunk in probably about six weeks at the
moment and as i'm getting older i'm
really losing and diminishing my
relationship with alcohol because
when i was younger my values for
happiness didn't sit around productivity
i could play xbox all day but as i'm
getting older my values are changing and
productivity is so important to me the
drinking alcohol now inflicts that
and even now i think to myself sometimes
drinking makes me less happy because it
negates my levels of productivity and
it's only as i'm getting older that i'm
starting to realize how important that
is to me
and i think that when we're younger we
don't quite see it that way we kind of
look to
use alcohol and especially in the
context of confidence
people
can buy bottled confidence and they buy
it in the version of alcohol because
it breaks down those social
struggles that they have it makes them
feel more confident or more importantly
it makes them care less and as long as
we have alcohol available to us people
don't need to work on their inadequacies
when it comes to social interactions or
having the confidence to do things
when you talk about productivity in that
context of you know you value it more
now than ever do you mean professional
productivity in all sense whether it's
having the energy on a sunday morning to
go you want to give me tennis you know
i'm rubbish at tennis but i like you
know you know when you throw a ball for
a dog how happy it is that's me chasing
the tennis ball around the tennis court
i'm awful but i enjoy just doing that or
productivity with work where so many
times i'll be in the shower and i'll
have an idea and the idea really excites
me
and people around me know that when i do
have an idea and i want to do it you
have to leave me alone to kind of hash
it out especially if i have a video idea
we could be going for breakfast if i
have a video idea i'm almost like
i can't enjoy breakfast while i've got
the idea in my head
when i'm hungover or tired or you know
on the road with tours and book signings
or whatever if i'm trying to burn the
candle too much i lose that spark to be
able to have these creative ideas and
four or five days into a stretch of not
having anything creative come in i feel
the pressure i'm posted in a few days
and to me that's important that i stay
on top of those things and you know be
creative and come up with new ideas and
i even have a set of standards it's
pretty peculiar where
i do look through my comments sometimes
although i know comments are the most
poisonous place to go the weight of one
negative comment outweighs 100 positive
but when someone says that's your best
video yet i've accomplished something
that's what i want
so
when i do go these long periods of time
without being productive in that sense
it starts to drain on me and i'm
starting to think
what am i doing
that's making me happy that's taking
away happiness from other areas of my
life professionally would you consider
yourself a workaholic
no but that could be denial because
i like working
and
it's it's a difficult one now where i do
have to distinguish things where i can't
watch a film on my own because i don't
see it as productive but if i watch a
film with my girlfriend that's fine
because i'm it's almost like a blocked
out on the calendar professional time
but then
at the same time i do like having down
time to train jiu jitsu skateboard to
the beach have a dip i'm not like on my
phone all the time i do like leaving my
phone in my car when i do stuff
but
i couldn't think of anything worse than
retirement this is why i kind of feel
everyone is
not brainwashed because i can't expect
everyone to have the same values as me
but when everyone's like oh you know buy
a house pay off the mortgage in 50 years
you can retire with that and i'm sure
that's great some people my dad loves
being retired but me that's my idea of
hell to wake up with nothing to do or no
problems to solve i think people
underestimate the human beings for
thousands of years have been problem
solvers with much worse problems than
what we have today
and the idea of just stopping that at a
point in time just drives me crazy but
then
i'm not sure if i'm just potentially
wired differently to other people and
you talked about your girlfriend
you've been in a relationship for how
long now
over a year
so did john i've always been very
skeptical of talking about relationships
on podcasts because by the time they go
out i'm no longer in a relationship so
is is one of those things but yeah i'm
incredibly happy and i think that
there has to come a point where
i actually did a magic mushroom trip uh
probably two years ago and about eight
of us we sat by the beach um we just
thought [ __ ] out and what was crazy was
if we went and got trolled on alcohol
and you know were absolute
caused chaos that's legal but for eight
of us to take some magic restrooms and
sit and think about life and share what
we're experiencing people that was
illegal
and
i had time to reflect on
i do see different areas of my life like
races and i like to be in competition
with people that don't even know i'm in
competition with them for years i'd have
a list of social media competitors that
i'd never spoken to and i'd worked
tirelessly to beat them
uh yeah and you know what
there was an element of envy and
bitterness and that fueled me in some
respects but
i sat there on the beach and i thought
to myself
what if you win the race of having the
most money and the most notoriety and
the most you know fame
but your friends that did the nine to
five and work to retirement got the wife
and the kids and the happy life and also
my mom and dad my family is very you
know traditional i thought
what really are they going to prefer me
coming home in a ferrari or me coming
home with a family and that was a really
big insight in my mind to
what's important to you that i impressed
my family yes because i want them to
think that their investment of you know
even now 33 years is gonna pay off and i
want them to one day sit back and go we
did a good job so it's very important
that i please my parents and i thought
i've really got to make sure that i
don't finish the race of life and have
the money in the fame and realized that
i was in the wrong race
and that was such a big epiphany for me
and i realized at that point that i was
going to have to work harder in
relationships
how many relationships did you have give
me a history of your sort of dating
track record someone just sighed in the
background over there no
i never really respected them or took
them seriously because
i thought that my young 20s and even my
mid-20s were
more important to accomplish other
things it was only as i got to my late
20s i realized hold on maybe these
values
might be good for
professional life but they won't be good
further down the line in 10 years time
in bondi there's a lot of
wealthy older men they've got the sports
cars and the young girlfriends i don't
envy them at all i don't ever think oh
i'd love to be 40 with a 25 year old
girlfriend i don't ever think like that
but
i think it's just been one of those
things where
carol dweck
in her book mindset talks about a fixed
mindset
um and an open mindset and i appreciate
that for so many things you could come
in today
with so many problems of the business
and my mindset is let's do this let's do
this we'll do this we'll turn this up
we'll do better on this we'll be fine
but with relationships i was very
fixed where if something went wrong i
was like ah
this this is your fault and we should
stop this right away and you can
appreciate in some people's lives when
things get tough they either take the
option of developing and becoming better
or they blame other people and
discontinue and i was fixed and i only
kind of realized that when i was older
and
the negatives in your 20s are [ __ ] a
relationship aren't that severe if
anything i was like oh i get to work
more you know i have more time to myself
how long was your longest relationship
probably about a year okay so the the
current relationship is up there with
your longest ever don't tell either but
extra pressure on it but yeah it is and
i think that
especially there's some crazy things
going on in society where
there are more women over 30 without
children than under 30 and i think that
that's that's a statistic that chris
williamson brought up on jordan peterson
when they had a chat and i was like
we're all
not appreciating family life
like the generation before us and i
don't think it's important that we take
their values as our own
but i think it's very easy like a kind
of rip in the sea to get taken out
without realizing that there's so much
in our lives that we can prioritize that
aren't the most important things
and my friends have got married and had
kids and families very early
there are some that feed the
confirmation bias or don't get married
right or you know but the majority of
them are very happy and just before we
started talking
um i was going to mention like the
things called the inner citadel where if
you can imagine that someone
uh for whatever reason is this in
response to the question asked about
monogamy yeah okay so before we start
recording i asked james if he believed
in monogamy so imagine you've got
someone who injures his leg and they
have to chop his leg off i might butcher
this what i'm saying
he then might
end up being angry at people that have
two legs and make up his own reason
actually do you know what two legs is
wasteland you know you don't need that
you only need one leg and because
something didn't work for him or his
his surroundings didn't suit what
happened to him he decided to tear
everyone else's down so when we talk
about monogamy
where there are people that are in open
relationships i often look at them and
you know i was going to say without
causing a fence [ __ ] them
who hurt you you know like at what point
did
is a societal structure being monogamous
but it's because there's a huge benefit
to doing that you're talking about
sacrifice you're talking about you know
primitive urges or whatever it is but at
the base of that you get to support a
family better so
i believe monogamy is good for
loads of reasons i do believe in it and
also my mom and dad are still together
they're each other's first girlfriend
and boyfriend
but i do find that people that come
along and try and tear down your beliefs
of monogamy
they're the people that it didn't work
for them so they want to burn the system
same in the dieting world where you've
got plus size models promoting body
positivity
i think there's some absolute credit to
that i'm a personal trainer so i cross
viewed that six-pack but
i think to them
they got [ __ ] over so much in the
pursuit of trying to get in shape that
they decided to tear the system down for
everyone else you know because it didn't
work for them they have to go around and
influence the way you see it
so i think that's one of the kind of
ways that i see things like monogamy i
think for the majority of people it's
perfect
but you're still going to get
well i'm assuming here but going to get
temptations and you know when we think
about the monogamy discussion i had this
conversation with my friends the other
day
there is
i'm going to stitch them all up i don't
care there's six of them
and it's split down the middle whether
they believe in monogamy or polygamy um
or whether they believe i wouldn't say
polygamy is necessarily that some of
their beliefs it's more like
is one partner for life the right thing
is marriage the right thing or do you
have like a child with somebody maybe
and then
the future you're probably gonna end up
with somebody else um the stats around
around this are showing i believe
that people are struggling to stay in
marriages
um as society develops
how how do we not
like are you not scared that
you'll lose the thing how do you not
lose the spark so remember we said about
the expectation in fact if you go into a
relationship expecting that you're gonna
cheat or you're gonna break up i don't
think that sets a good foundation for it
again i would like to go into a
relationship and potentially a marriage
or whatever
fully believing in it but being happy to
be wrong and if i get divorced later on
in life as long as i tried my hardest
and i committed i can take that i could
take that as a loss or whatever it is
but
somehow in this debate we've lost the
ability to try your hardest at something
and you know what
if 10 15 years down the line you do lose
it be amicable about it don't destroy
someone's life and make them feel like a
piece of [ __ ] because you cheated cheat
them or whatever instead just call a
spade a spade and be like look
we might not be the same people we were
when we met
i think people should try the best and
try and build a stable home to bring up
a child because that's what i've been
exposed to and if it doesn't work it
doesn't work i also don't think the
people should force the marriage at the
point that it's broken because i think
that two people under a house that
resent each other trying to bring up a
family it's probably better off just
having parents in two different
households and get more gifts for
christmas or whatever it is but do you
think cheating is a lack of discipline
in some respect and you know what the
majority of it yes because we do get
urges and i think you know we're we're
[ __ ]
we're monkeys in suits right we we are
chimps at the end of the day we are
organized apes
we have come from a lineage of [ __ ]
each other up for so long like you go
back a hundred years a thousand years
the wars that we've had all humans have
ever done
is get territorial on bits of land and
kill each other right savages you know
you watch braveheart you're like wow
imagine being a imagine being a soldier
back then or you watched 300 and you're
like wow these guys were spearing each
other been going for lunch
so
you know we are forcing our dna and who
we are into this kind of preset mold of
you know do you take you to be a lawful
of course there's going to be a lot of
people that don't sue that i think at
the moment as well there's so many
options
there's so much availability so many
secret places to slide dm
linkedin private message or your house
app that could be used like tinder
whatever it is no idea you could do that
one so how's that
neither did i
yeah [ __ ] so like uh there's there's
so many different places that avenues
people can go you know back in the day
if you wanted to take someone for a date
when you've got a wife you could be seen
out you could be seen you know talking
to that person i think the repercussions
of being a [ __ ] house are probably a lot
less severe now and
i think that
the way society is going is worrying it
is definitely worrying that there are so
many options and what was that website
was it ashley madison
it was a dating site for married people
all right so if you wanted to be like
look we need to be hidden away at a bar
and have millions of users so straight
away i think it was brought down by that
hacking group anonymous or whatever i
could have got that wrong but
so there are so many people it could
also be
other things like a lack of confidence
in your partner it could be a lack of
confidence in your relationship it could
be all these things but
in my mind
i think better that you you go for
something that feels right if you're
someone that sits here and goes i do not
want to get married i'm not saying you
know it's going to fit everyone but i
think if you're someone that
importantly there are sacrifices and
when i look to get married it's not just
about the relationship i have with that
person it's about creating a stable
platform to bring up children but again
we're almost bred in society like we can
never be wrong ignorance is not a bad
thing we are all ignorant to so much the
majority of people couldn't tell you
anything really substantial about
history you know we don't know that much
about so many things i don't know what
the motorways are called in the north
all of these things so we're allowed to
be ignorant of these things and we're
allowed to be wrong but it doesn't mean
we shouldn't endeavor to get the best
possible outcome
i am i remember my girlfriend said to me
one day in it you know when your
girlfriend says something you kind of
rubbish at the time you deny it and then
later you're thinking about it it's one
of those things she said to me she was
like do you actually want to be in a
relationship or are you doing it because
you know it's the right thing to do it's
a very important question
and it's and it's funny because a lot of
what you were saying was related to you
know you know you should it's the right
thing to do etc but deep in your core
you know you talked a little bit about
the fact that we're all monkeys and what
would the monkey want to do
would do you actually want to be if you
could have an alternative option would
you choose the alternative option where
you have the upsides of the relationship
and also the upsides of being single is
that what you believe most
most people would choose i could be
getting this wrong as well but there's
something called the hot cold empathy
gap i think that's what it's called
where when we're angry it's very hard to
imagine being calm when we're hot it's
very hard to imagine being cold when
you're in one state of consciousness the
opposing state feels very hard to
reconcile
so
when you're single and you're [ __ ]
strangers and you're feeling very numb
afterwards and thinking why the [ __ ] did
i do that post not clarity uh as a lot
of people call it you're thinking car
what i do for a relationship what i
would do to
[ __ ] someone and want them to stay you
know but then when you're in a
relationship you get the opposite when
you're in a relationship you're thinking
oh it could be nice to sleep with a
stranger or whatever it is
i think that we're always they say grass
is greener is very you know cliche but
we're always looking at that opposing
sense of feelings how we're feeling now
and almost curious about it
but i think there are dangers of you
know say you do want to open your
relationship you're opening the door to
catastrophic things should they happen
and
i think that there is definitely like a
a
hard hard wiring side of things where
you know if you want that sense of
freedom on your side cool but they're
going to probably need that sense of
freedom on theirs and yeah it might seem
like a good idea now whilst you're in
the position of only slept with one
person for five years but then when you
experience the polar opposite
realization and reality what if you
realize you made a grave error you can't
undo seeing or knowing or experiencing
that so
again i'm not i'm not they're like this
guy's been in a relationship but yeah
he's giving us all advice no i get it i
i think i've arrived at the same
conclusion i read the game that pick up
artists book and then i read his sequel
to it where he realizes that like much
of what the way he'd chosen to live and
live was wrong you know he becomes the
best pickup artist in the world he then
tries polygamy and realizes polygamy is
actually not the right approach and
doesn't need to happiness and then
decides the monogamy
um and generally when i think about all
the things that are worth it in my life
they come at a
a sacrifice
there's something else i have to choose
instead if i want a six-pack can't
choose waffles every day if i want
waffles i don't get the six-pack and so
the six-pack itself is in fact just a
story it's a story of sacrifice of
discipline it's a story about who you
are and that's why it's perceived to be
valuable i think
for me a relationship is is valuable
because it's a story of commitment and
all the other things you said no to to
say yes to this that's part of what
actually gives it its intrinsic value so
and the six-pack is valuable because
it's hard to obtain that's why we give
it value and the story around the same
yeah they're hard to obtain now they're
they're difficult it requires work like
a six-pack exactly and you've got the
temptations whether it's a chocolate
cake or a single person or maybe not
even single but
you need to really have like a clear set
idea on on what you want and again to
lean on your values and it's interesting
you say about the book the game you
realized in the first
the the call to action wasn't so much a
system but a belief in a system
and there is every chance that the
systems i've put in that book
might not actually hold any weight but
if someone believes they will they could
end up working a bit like the game you
tell someone this is how it works they
have full faith in it and
it's an interesting one that some people
just need to know that it can happen and
for instance
i talk about the link we spoke about
confidence and anxiety confidence and
inspiration also sit
on a parallel with each other because
to get inspired by someone what we
really do is getting confidence from
seeing it happen
so you think about someone like joe
rogan started off with being audacious
he then inspired us by allowing us to
feel more confident about the chance
that that could happen
and
there are two trails that people go with
this and this was really interesting
when i wrote about it people see your
success this success the podcast they go
two ways one they're bitter and they
[ __ ] want to hate you for it or two
they're inspired and you without knowing
it are projecting confidence into the
lives of hundreds of thousands because
you're showing them it can be done i
think it was nelson mandela that said
no one believes it's possible until it's
done and a good friend of mine lucy
lloyd she
bought me a little
card that had it on it and gave it to me
and i stuck out my window when i first
got to sydney
and
it's so important that people do try
their hardest endeavors like
relationships because without knowing it
they're going to be friends even your
group of six people in that group
that you're inspiring them without even
knowing it and inspiration doesn't mean
you have to be the best relationship in
the world but you're showing people it
works
so
i think that the buck doesn't just stop
at sacrifice it also my parents would
have inspired me my dad said the key to
a happy marriage is accepting you're
wrong even when you're right
you talk a lot about dating in them in
the book at different times
chapter six you talk about dating apps
again and your relationship with dating
apps and
how uh
you've been you've had kind of like an
on off relationship with dating apps
when i was thinking about writing my
next book one of the topics i was going
to write about was modern dating because
it appears to me that there's a
generation that have kind of been caught
in the technological transition almost
so what i mean it's it's really it's a
very big topic and when i was writing
the book i was thinking [ __ ] this isn't
the dating book mate there's gonna be a
lot of married people reading this and i
say to them two things i go one
there might be something in there that
doesn't change your life but it could
[ __ ] change someone else's right and
even if you don't have many friends you
could instill that in your kids or
whatever it is and
dating is such a big topic because it is
actually an incredibly big pain point
because people either don't have the
confidence required to meet someone or
they might not have the confidence to
leave someone and
when i spoke about the sunk cost fallacy
people remaining invested in something
purely based off their previous endeavor
whether it's time energy resources
there are so many people out there that
if you ask them why they're with their
partner they give you the amount of time
they've already invested i've been
within four years yeah do i throw it
away so you're already giving people
confidence to leave a relationship and
if you think you've got professional
life home life and health there's three
things
a lot of advice we need to give people
is around dating and
it's been
maybe three years since i've touched
alcohol on a date
because i realized how much alcohol
skews the dating scene as well and even
my girlfriend won't mind me saying this
but
it got to the point where i would drink
to kill nerves before a date and you
might meet someone and straight away
look at my god this isn't going to work
but then three drinks in you oh kind of
all right and then before you know it
you shagged a stranger on a weeknight
you're hungover at work and you put
yourself off dating again because you
know that when you first met them you
didn't want that and the next day you
did and you you're painting dating in a
negative light and
even how i met
my girlfriend now
i would say to people
let's meet and do something whether it's
going for a swim in the sea going for a
walk have you got a dog trying to get a
coffee and i actually like the idea of
moving with someone the two places i
find the most
uh
organic conversations are driving and
walking
driving when you're not sat facing each
other and it's not quite so
interview-esque people really open up
and they're also in a place that's very
relaxing for them and when you go for a
walk and there's movement involved i
feel it feels less interview-esque you
say to me like let's remove dating out
the context i want you to sit with a
stranger and drink alcohol with them
with a small chance they'll be
compatible like no
imagine you know that's ludicrous i
don't want to do that but when you break
it down again like the fear and
insecurities whatever okay if the date
is too much what about getting an ice
cream at the beach okay that's something
i can do and as long as you're not
trying to lose weight
doing a swim on a monday an ice cream on
a tuesday a coffee on a wednesday people
will think you're a bit promiscuous but
you know i mean
then you can get more dates in and again
we're going back into my marketing
analogy
surely seeing five people in a week for
20 30 minutes each is going to be better
for your
general building of prospects than it
would be getting smashed on a thursday
night and shagging a stranger you're
never going to talk to again so even the
way people perceive dating can be hugely
changed and you talk about dating ups
there's one in london it's called
thursday yeah i know yeah where was that
when i needed it
because there is so much small talk on
social media where
oh yeah what you're doing this weekend i
like that idea but
it's giving us one of many walls we can
hide behind because dating is difficult
and it removes sorry i've got a
boyfriend fake numbers
which i must have given my number wrong
uh
people are hiding behind that and
confidence isn't like an award it's not
like a trophy that i give you to go on
your wall well i don't see about it
you're confident it's more like fitness
where if you stop training it you'll
lose it and you'll lose it a lot quicker
than you probably would expect so
people don't realize that
with so many things they're paying into
this bit like fitness but like going to
the gym or going for a run and when you
put up this massive stop like i'm going
to use dating apps although some people
do
find love and
meet their forever person on there
without realizing it they are reducing
them their ability to train that area of
them a bit like when you maybe don't do
work for a week you go back and sit in
front of your laptop how does this work
again
so there is a negative
definitely
that goes along with the positive like
newton's laws where you've got all this
convenience on one side you're
definitely breeding weakness on the
other what is it that you
when you know that someone isn't going
to fulfill what they say they want to do
what are the cues of that like i was
just thinking because i'm thinking about
a particular friend who continually says
says they want to go to the gym and they
continually say they want to change
their life
but there's just no
um there's but there's been no change in
like 10 years
and as a friend i'm getting like
exhausted by you know sometimes i'm like
i talk about a lot in the podcast with
when i have psychologists and stuff on
i'm like am i overstepping my mark for
even wanting to
help them it's a difficult one i'm the
same where i've actually found myself
turning into an [ __ ] yeah i don't
want to be an [ __ ] with my friends
because i feel like maybe there's that
point i'll get to where i finally will
click and then i realize i'm actually
ruining the relationship a little bit
amen i'm like are my friends now
resenting me because i'm trying to help
them
and
yeah it i had a bit of a not falling out
actually having a chat with a friend and
he said to me oh it's all right for you
and we were living together at the time
and i said well i didn't live with
someone who had a [ __ ] million
followers when i was starting my
business
you know like and i said that to him and
i said when i was starting out as a pt i
didn't have any friends i could lean on
to do stuff and i was trying i said i'll
do anything you want for you to start
this business i'm here for you you can
have my instagram for a week and promote
your business whatever it is like
but then you say yeah the the talk and
the actions don't always add up and then
you get to a point where you're like do
i want what's best for them or do i
preserve the relationship in that
situation what do you think the blocker
is belief
belief yeah i think they want it but
they don't really think they can do it
confidence is that this similar
yeah and they they portray confidence in
some areas of their life tremendously
but i i think the main thing is belief i
think they want to believe they can do
it but they don't truly believe it and
unfortunately action must come first and
you must actually prove to yourself that
it can be done and that requires a lot
of work without any gratification people
don't realize that
you say about everyone knowing how to
lose weight on the outside it's almost
like a macro cycle but really the micro
cycle is the tiny habits in between so
someone can go i need to eat less and
move more but like that's nuanced really
we dive that down we go
okay
let's go
no food till 1 pm let's go
you know two big meals maybe one snack
whatever and then we go okay 10 000
steps a day although that does attribute
to the macro the big thing that's
happening we still must give them the
small steps whether it's with a business
where you say like they you know their
big macro strategy is to post more on
social media but the micro is one post
every day answering someone's questions
doing this doing that i think that if
people's first stepping stone to where
they think they need to go is too big
they'll never take the step
and what i do as a coach
in many facets of my life is to make
that first stepping stone so small they
have no other option to take it super
interesting because what you said there
you know the start start of that was um
about how you in essence people people
want evidence in order to start but
the truth is
when you start you get the evidence
and i see that a lot in people you know
people coming up to me saying i've got
this business idea they'll come up to me
in the gym all the time and say i've got
this business idea and then you'll hear
the next thing they'll say is all the
excuses that they've put in front of
them starting and i really mean that
like it literally is like i've got this
great idea i think it's going to change
the world
but and then they explain all the things
they're imperfect about timing or
funding or i just need to wait for this
or this or whatever
and really under underpinning all of
that is a lack of belief and like you're
right like when i started i'm sure when
you started um i didn't have evidence i
didn't have sufficient evidence that i
knew what i was doing but i gained the
evidence which resulted in belief from
stumbling forward in a very messy way
for some reason people a lot of people
need the evidence first and we have this
as well with imposter syndrome and some
people rebuke imposter syndrome but
we need to realize that every single
person is going to feel like an imposter
you get someone macho going no not me
but we will and
i like to point out to people that you
will at some point be an imposter
objectively even being a parent for the
first time
you have no previous experience bringing
a child into the world so the beginning
you need to pretty much lie to yourself
and go i'm a good parent and then after
three months and your young baby your
child hasn't got any bruises on his head
you're like well i've got evidence i'm a
good charge you know he didn't fall over
and hit his head on a table or whatever
and the same in any endeavor your first
podcast you did on diary ceo you would
have had to say
i'm a good podcaster with no evidence
that you are but then a hundred episodes
and you go [ __ ] i'm actually all right
you are very good by the way as a
podcast i think i just acted like one
but then again you're being the person
you need to be yeah and that's a massive
part of confidence as well the the first
thing that people need to have a real
clear vision on is who they need to be
and that was the first thing that
projected me from
not being an inherently confident person
should have seen the sweat patches i had
from the last episode you know and i'm
not trying to masquerade that fact i'm
not trying to hide it up or be you know
dishonest with people instead i have so
many internal conversations with myself
about who i need to be today because we
do need to become a persona in certain
situations like being a father for the
first time like doing your first
business sales pitch like
starting your first podcast or your
first
first day as ceo when you get promoted
from a business you might go from
director to managing director there is
an element of you having to be an
imposter but you have to take it upon
yourself with beliefs that you can do it
because you can't get the evidence that
you're good at it before you start
if i spoke to your girlfriend and i
asked her i said what does james need to
work on
what would she say
oh
oh yeah nice pattern i uh
patience
interesting i have a very active mind
and i'm actually in the process of
trying to arrange getting an adhd test
as an adult because people i know that
have been diagnosed in their older life
say it's
really benefited them understanding how
their mind works
and
sometimes i get so excited of doing
things
that will please me
i have blinkers on to other people
whether other people want to relax right
now or other people you know don't want
to be in the room while i'm filming
content or whatever it is and i feel
that sometimes i need to be more patient
and go okay here's the idea write it
down and do it tomorrow that's one of
the things that
it's only after i've done it where i
think i had no consideration for anyone
else then because
i created a pain point in my head that i
wanted to action that
and i always break down our
personalities and this could be a really
weird way to think of it like a tribe
you know whether you've got lefties and
you know people on the right whether
you've got aggressive people or calm
people we're all part of an ecosystem
that we need the audacious people that
you know are gonna be impatient and do
things we need the critical thinkers and
people that are more logistic with that
but if you look at the 16 personalities
none of those personalities are
confident confident isn't a personality
trait you've got debater entrepreneur
one of these things
so people need to appreciate that even
though as an ecosystem we all need to be
vastly different confidence doesn't sit
as a personality trait it sets it's
almost like a set of values that each
and every person can have because some
things that we have are predetermined
like heights and yes height can be
influenced by the amount of nutrition
you get growing up or whatever
but
ultimately it doesn't matter if you're
introvert extrovert whether you're
patient impatient
everyone
really confidence is your
almost set of beliefs you have
surrounding something based on previous
experiences
i could get you the most least confident
person ever so i'm shy timid sat here
i go what do you like at driving
93 of people say they're above average
at driving which doesn't make sense as a
statistic human beings are massively
capable of being over confidence
machines most uh exoneration cases are
from faulty eyewitnesses so whenever
anyone's exonerated i think maybe 70
the reasons why from 40 eyewitnesses if
i said was that guy wearing a red top
you go yeah yeah it definitely was so we
do have the ability to be overconfident
we're just not utilizing it in all the
areas of our lives that we should
that kind of brings you back to that
point about um about evidence when you
said the thing about driving because if
i've never crashed a car
i would i think i've got evidence of um
being good at driving but then in other
facets of my life i might not have that
evidence yeah i think i'm really trying
to understand that that point about
evidence is confidence just a
a result of the evidence we do or
subjective evidence whether correct or
incorrect that we've gained in different
areas like i could be
you know if i'd crashed my car every day
i could be really confident on stage and
on podcasts and in dates and whatever if
i've had loads of positive reinforcement
in terms of evidence there but really
unconfident in cars so uh in part of the
book i come up with my own kind of
theory with this and i say that we must
take into account that the history of
someone will have an
influence on
how they perceive the world but that
doesn't mean it's fixed so you might
have you know
asked some people on a date and never
got a successful wave face to face but
that doesn't mean you're doomed forever
you know you might go oh you know my
ability to talk to someone to get the
number it's just not that good or how
many people have you asked that number
are three it's not something fixed that
we can never develop on the other side
of things where people will be
overconfident in certain scenarios it's
also
the availability bias turns into this as
well where we make decisions based on
the information that's available to us
so
i've had a fun deep dive with this where
people
have a fear of flying much more people
have a fear of flying than they do fear
of driving but driving that same
distance as far as fatality is much more
dangerous your chances of dying driving
are tremendously higher shark attacks
again in australia everyone goes you go
in the sea it's really dangerous i go
mate you're like
so many times more likely to drown than
you are to get bitten by a shark but no
one's getting in the water being afraid
of drowning and that is the biggest
cause of death i believe on bondi beach
where i live
so much of what we perceive the outside
world to be is really created and
curated by what's available to us and
our friendship circles are massively you
know influenceable on that as well
even you having three out of six of your
friends that don't believe in monogamy
that's going to influence your
availability bias of what you think
is capable in a relationship there's so
much more to the topic of confidence
than just your your history it's also
your current and who you're with
i guess even that's that friendship
circle all those you know that is a form
of evidence as well like if my friends
are telling me that i am a
a useless scumbag whether they're saying
it directly or just with a facial
expression um that is adding somewhat to
my self-story which is this formation of
evidence i have about myself and that
could lead me to be pessimistic in my
endeavors or optimistic are you saying
to like are you advising people to
chop these people out of their circles
the term i use is picking your
passengers where if i said you got to
drive eight hours tomorrow that's one
thing but if i say i'm putting someone
in the car with you that's something
completely different altogether and
for eight hours you would be so
meticulous on who you go with i'm sure
that if it was someone you didn't really
get on with you'd be like can we not
just get him a driver and drive him up
you know
your space in your car is so you know
private to you and important to you and
again even when you are traveling around
or whatever it is
having people with you that are going to
drain you of energy becomes almost like
a cost
and by going on your own or with someone
better picked you're going to be able to
improve your productivity your sense of
the way you see things so we do need to
appreciate that people we surround
ourselves with are either going to be a
headwind or a wind in our sails they can
be the neutral lot but we must take note
of that and i'm not saying that if
anyone causes you any issues get rid of
them but you need to weigh it up in the
long term because if you're with someone
who's got a pessimistic outlook on life
in the world and they're not going to
change irrespective of how much you help
them they will hinder your net position
so the values of how much your net
position is important to you and your
family and people around you
you might have to make the decision to
let that person go
in the book you reference jordan
peterson um you talk about this utility
deprivate utility of deprivation concept
a word a phrase i've never heard before
um
please explain it to me and why you felt
it was contextually relevant to this
topic i went down a rabbit hole and
jordan peterson you know i don't agree
with everything he says that's that's
the that's the term
disclaimer i do not agree yeah yeah but
i do agree with the majority of things
he says and masturbation is something
that we kind of just you know
porn and
only fans we're kind of like oh you know
let people live but
you know there are some only fans models
being murdered by their fans whereas
some of us might think oh it's good for
society we've got
porn where men can access more naked
women in an hour
than a man could ever access in a life
20 30 40 years ago
that again newton's laws of opposites
every action opposite reaction that's
gonna be doing things to people and if
i'm in a bar and i'm like you know i
really want to talk to that person again
i'm using a data knowledge it could be
anything if i go home and masturbate to
some really hot people in porn
i'd be like oh no i'm just getting
another beer with my mates you know so
having that utility of deprivation and
if you abstain from and i'm not saying
i'm not anti-porn or nofap or whatever
they call it
i'm just saying to people to consider
the implications if you stop if you're
someone who's lonely and you're single
could abstaining from masturbation
improve your net position [ __ ]
probably because you're going to be in a
position where you can't just get the
gas out the release valve every now and
then that suits your purpose because
even some people are getting
desensitized to sexual intimacy because
of the amount of time they're spending
much important that's not good for
anyone imagine you get to 40 and the
idea of actually [ __ ] someone doesn't
seem as good as the idea of what's
important and this is something
especially with young people
they realize well the reality of having
sex when you're 16 and what you've
watched on porn is vastly different so
we cannot say that this is just a
net benefit or a net positive thing for
people so the utility of deprivation is
to appreciate that sacrificing some
things in your life has a positive
effect to stop drinking for instance
will have a net positive on other areas
of your life to stop eating junk food or
at least reduce the amount or reduce
your adiposity the amount of body fat
you have there is a utility to depriving
yourself although
porn is great fast food is great and all
of these things although that's great
there is a utility and a benefit to
depriving yourself of them have you
deprived yourself of masturbation
masturbation in general
i'm in a healthy relationship so i
haven't really got the time to do it as
i did before the urges are there
sometimes don't get me wrong because
it's also a form of escapism you know
people might fantasize about sleeping
with other people and i think that if
any you haven't got the time to do it
that's [ __ ] no but like
that is [ __ ] you're right that's my
i'm kind of trying to fill the gap there
with like some kind of defense you could
probably do it now and i wouldn't know
it's like
now you said not to make the table make
a noise
so it's one of those things where
you know i'm not saying make it illegal
get rid of porn i'm not saying that i'm
saying that we need to take note of the
the conveniences in our life and i
completely get that i'm just asking from
a personal perspective it's a thing that
i've been thinking a lot about because
i'm in a relationship as well and um
i do believe that my intimate
relationship with my partner will not be
as good if i masturbate all the time i
my desire won't be there so if i
masturbated at 9 00 pm and then i got in
bed with my partner at 10 p.m i'm gonna
want to sleep
and especially if they if you've somehow
misinterpreted where you're at in the
day and then
an arm comes around and goes hey babe
and you're like [ __ ] yeah so
there'll be
a lot of female listeners that can't
appreciate to the full extent what it's
like to be a man once you've ejaculated
and they call it post that clarity and
all these things i'm sure i'm going to
be absolutely slammed for saying this
but it is a change in
in psychology like instantly there's no
other way that you can experience it
again the hot cold empathy gap when
you're horny you can't imagine not
having a sex drive and when you've not
got a sex drive you can't imagine being
horny but you know
it's one of those things where we just
need to take it into consideration and
for someone if i was to sit opposite
someone today and go could your life be
better if you stopped drinking as much
they say yeah you should probably
[ __ ] not drink as much could your
life be better and your day tonight be
better if you stop wanking to porn yeah
well maybe stop wanking to porn or at
least do it less i think my entire life
would be better if i stopped wanking to
porn i do because i think i'd have a
better relationship i genuinely do i
think you would look forward to
the intimacy way more if you knew the
only way that you were going to get it
was with your part i mean
there's me saying masturbation is
intimacy but you would look forward to
it a lot more um if you weren't getting
the
releasing the valve
in your hotel room while you're in
london promoting your book
what did you have cameras
but you're right it is one of those
things where it's a complex topic and
i'm not coming in it from a position of
expertise when you said that i thought
i've never heard it put so succinctly
that there is a benefit to abstaining
from things that you like
and liver king exact same philosophy he
goes
we don't eat the liver because we like
the toast we do it because it's good for
us and he's like no one likes training
but we do it because do i sound like him
it's like he's like he's in the room
again yeah yeah so it's it's one of
those things where we must appreciate
some things
you know pure net benefit aren't going
to benefit us in a long time now if
you're in a relationship and you're
masturbating i would say
that maybe isn't as severe as being
single and masturbating because
being in a relationship and say you
masturbate here and there or you have a
long shower and enjoy yourself that's
one thing but if you're single and doing
it you're preventing yourself from going
down the path of doing something you
need to do which is to
you know be more proactive in meeting a
suitable life partner and again someone
say i'm brainwashed or this guy's
monogamy brainwashed or whatever at
least if you're in a relationship you're
not hindering your potential quite to
the extent of inaction on this side
what is your goal
like what is your do you have a goal in
terms of your life when you think about
what you're trying to achieve right now
from being here from what you've done
over the last month what is it what is
it you're trying to do
i was i got to shoreditch this morning
about quarter to seven couldn't get a
coffee so i'm walking down the road to
try and find something
and
i ended up going down the road and a
lady just said thank you and i said what
for
and she goes you changed my life and i
was like thank you i was talking to her
and she started crying and i get very
awkward i get awkward when someone gets
me like a birthday present when people
are like oh get the cake out of [ __ ]
sake i
even at christmas it feels weird to be
given gifts i just feel very awkward and
i feel like
me just going thanks for that isn't
enough so now i find myself putting it
on like guys you didn't have to that's
fake i just it weirds me out so when
people compliment me in real life i get
very awkward and my friends laugh about
it they're like you know relax mate
she's just saying thank you and then she
started crying and i was like what am i
done
and
to me this is a very very strange thing
that a stranger would cry seeing me when
i've never met them spoken to them on
the phone or messaged them
so
from that interaction it's apparent that
there is a net positive effect for what
i'm doing and i do take pleasure in that
even though i do find it incredibly
awkward
so for me that small interaction there
kind of pays into this pot that this
little crusade i'm on of trying to
eradicate [ __ ] and i'm definitely
roughing up some people on one side but
on the other side i'm making people's
lives better i think [ __ ] this that
makes me feel good that's a selfish
endeavor i'm helping people because it
makes me feel good but
i'd like to continue that and at the
same time i live i live a great life you
know
it sounds really cliche people go
i have something that other people will
never have and that's enough
and that's how i feel all the time so
yeah
it's a bit crazy what was the worst day
of your life
13th of march 2017.
i went to i was in sydney i'd been there
and personal training in the uk
did well earned good money
uh lived in my parents moved out moved
back in for a bit
my mum and dad were heroes for me when i
was doing the long hours and you have to
do i remember someone saying as a
personal trainer get your first thousand
hours under your belt because once
you've done that everything else is easy
i just focused on that
and
it went really well my mom and dad
helped me my mum would leave leftover
food for breakfast so i'd literally be
eating like yorkshire pudding on roast
potatoes at nine o'clock in the morning
cold at the tupperware
and then i'd come home from rugby at
like 9 30 in the evening my mom's like
give me a washing you know you go to bed
so then when i went to australia that's
what i wanted to do again just
face-to-face personal training but i
went into a gym with 32 other personal
trainers during who's listening
somewhere here was the only person that
introduced himself to me at 32 pts
whether it was because he saw her
struggling or the fact that i was
english he was just a nice guy and he
was like hey mate i want to get a coffee
and i pissed off so many of the other
personal trainers by prospecting so hard
on my first day that one of the trainers
said he said if you talk to my client
again i'll take your head off
i was like wow this is a competitive gym
and for the first six weeks in that gym
that i met during
i was failing i was not creating a
client base
i was doing 25 30 hours of pt a week in
the uk i moved to paradise now
struggling to do six hours and this is a
crazy thing now i'm in sydney and people
go james i love your stuff i go well in
2016 no one loved it i couldn't even get
people in for a free session
i would say to people like hey mate can
i give you a couple tips with the
exercise you do and they're like now
and so
i've gone from this stage in my life
where
that was demoralizing because at least
if someone told me to [ __ ] off when
they're doing a pec fly
in my old gym i could go into the pt
room and have banter with other pts we'd
pick ourselves up and go oh don't talk
to him mr grumpy guards doesn't want any
help even though he can't contract his
chest or whatever but in this gym i kind
of had nowhere to go
so
on the 13th of march i sat in an area
called australia square
and my two housemates said how's it
going and i was like no good
i was like
i was thinking about the fact i might
have to move back home to my parents and
i've just moved into paradise
the week before i had to borrow about
500 pound off my dad to buy a sofa i
still have that sofa now
and like being 27 at the time messaging
my dad and asking him to paypal me 500
quid so i could buy a sofa and some of
the ikea stuff i was like it doesn't
feel good because
i had everything i wanted in the uk i
was doing well i went to follow my
dreams and then suddenly i was borrowing
money from my dad at [ __ ]
at the age where i shouldn't have to
and that was the point for me where i
was like
i need to do things differently so
there's a street called pit street i
walked down it and there was an office
works and went into office works i
bought a whiteboard and some markers
and it was only 2pm in the afternoon i
was like i'm done went home 3pm
3pm in australia it's 6am in the uk
so i set up a tripod got my iphone i
didn't have to edit didn't know how to
record
i had to do a speech for three minutes i
had about 3 000 followers
live on facebook with the use of
whiteboard the first one got maybe like
100 likes and i was like i've gone
[ __ ] viral
and i decided that i was gonna do my six
hours of pt try the best i could which
wasn't even enough to survive at that
point but then i was going to go home
and do everything i could to build an
online on online following and to build
an online business
and that was in march by may i left the
gym
still had to pay rent for a year
but i had one remaining client he
actually i made more money staying at
home than i did going to the gym and i
had one client and she said to me she
couldn't afford to go to a festival so i
said instead of paying me 120 which is
like 65 pounds i said bring me a gift i
like training you we have fun just bring
me a gift so she come in she's like i've
got you a lululemon hoodie so sick cost
less than the pt session
so i'd go in and skateboard in and i
would literally just go in to train this
client for free but she'll have a gift
to me and all the other pts were like is
it your birthday i was like i don't
charge money to my clients anymore i
have an online business but if it wasn't
for that day where i literally i had the
lump in my throat when i was messing my
mates and i was like i'm not good at
work i'm failing a pt business which is
the only reason i came to australia
if it wasn't for that
i wouldn't i got the whiteboard i
wouldn't have got the markers and i
wouldn't have gone home and gone live on
facebook which just so happened to be
the beginning of a compounding effect to
build a following
it was then 50 000 followers i bought a
camera learned how to edit terribly my
first video that i ever filmed
uh without a iphone was one that did an
aloe vera i didn't know how to wet the
camera didn't know how to edit properly
i did one long piece that i put on
facebook i was like aloe vera in that
[ __ ] sunburn were you drinking it for
fat loss oh you're an idiot and
although that was kind of like
not even that bad like no one died but
in the same respect that all wins feel
the same all losses can feel the same so
it's not competition if you sell a
business for five million dollars and
someone else sells one for 500 million
you don't get a different dopamine and
serotonin you're not on an uber
surcharge you're not waking up like oh
my god i feel amazing
but the same with pain for me to
struggle in my business which is very
important to me someone might go well
yeah my dog died and i said well we're
both [ __ ] sad this isn't a
competition but to me that was really
one of the times i was like
this is [ __ ] but i'm so grateful to the
version of myself back then that took
action from that
because
one of my favorite quotes in that book
was from
uh one of the most famous martial
artists of all time called hixton gracie
and he goes losing is not the same as
being defeated
and that was massive you said it on my
podcast where he goes you can lose but
if you turn up and you go again you've
not been defeated so if someone competes
in jiu jitsu and they lose a match
that's cool but if you lose and you
never compete again as far as i'm
concerned you were defeated that day so
for me social strategy whatever it is if
people can appreciate whether it's
asking for a number ask him for a pay
rise start in a business
losing is one thing being defeated is
something completely different it's one
of the quotes you said in chapter three
in the book is the key to confidence is
being happy to lose i thought that was
really
a really simple way of saying a lot
people seem to correlate confidence with
success but that's completely wrong
confidence is much more of a
relationship to failure and
i stumbled across that by accident with
the door knocking i was completely fine
someone told me to [ __ ] off knocking on
their door to sell empower i was like
cool one in 100 is a cell that's one of
the 99. so
you know it becomes that point on the pt
even on the floor trying to help the guy
with these pec flights him telling me to
[ __ ] off i was so fine with that because
i knew i'd have to talk to finite amount
of people to get sale so when people can
be truly happy with with losing not
being happy with being defeated very
different then you build a sense of
confidence and if we all imagine our
friend that's got the most confidence in
the world they're just beaming with it
all the time
if something doesn't go right for them
and they fail
how much does it affect them
often not a lot because they're not
caught up with failing they're caught up
with
what or how many times they would have
to fail to accomplish success but if
i've got a self story based on this goes
back to one of the points i raised
earlier based on the fact that when i
was
eight years old i did public speaking on
stage and it went so badly that when i
got off stage all the kids on the
playground abused me one of them threw
an apple at my head
you know the girl that i was dating with
my little playground relationship dumped
me
when i when i grow up my self-story
around the consequence of public
speaking
failure will be
trauma-centric
and so
for those individuals presumably
confidence is much harder to attain in
if confidence is evidence you've got a
pretty big mountain of evidence to
overcome
with positive evidence um
in order to change your your belief and
that's why i'm trying to understand the
role of trauma in
in confidence and belief
so what i would say to this is if we can
try and develop a sense of gratitude
towards these inadequacies because those
inadequacies even from eight years old
public speaking show you the path to
progression without understanding and
really dialing down to where you're
inadequate you can't have a path and so
many people that are kind of lost in
life they're like i don't know what i
should do in my life cool well can you
identify something that you're insecure
about and can you work on it again i'm
insecure about how i look naked can you
work on it yeah then [ __ ] work on it
because
you know
again i think it was simon sinek who sat
opposite you and he goes
passion comes as a byproduct not reason
to start something it's a reason you
remain invested in something
and people need to appreciate that
passion may not exist in their life
right now and it might not exist for
another five years because you might do
another career for two years and you
[ __ ] hate it and then you do another
for three and you'd love it three years
in you feel passionate about it so if
you're five years away from truly
feeling passionate about your work
what can you do today you can work on
your inadequacies whatever it is and it
doesn't have to be this huge mountain of
you know oh i'm gonna ask a supermodel
in a day it doesn't have to be that you
don't have to double your salary asking
for a pay rise you just need to do
something that you could do to develop
your inadequacies would that be your tip
because there's going to be people
listening and i can almost sometimes
when i'm recording this podcast the way
that i decide what question to ask the
guest is i just go down the lens i go
through the lens into the person that i
know is listening and i know
that there'll be a suzanne walking her
dog this morning who's got a confidence
issue as it relates to
just herself and her life generally
maybe she might characterize it as low
self-esteem she struggles to take action
against the things that she calls her
ambitions what is the the actionable
place for su what's the if there was one
actionable thing to take away from this
what would that be where does what does
suzanne do today i'll be taking this one
from tim ferriss i'll fully credit him
fine we'll cut that out you can just own
it steal it so there's a exercise online
which is very popular in asking 10
discount on a coffee
and everyone's like really attacked this
because they think it's about the
discount it's not it's about looking
[ __ ] stupid so the next time you
order a cup of coffee you're to ask for
a 10 discount not because you expect to
get one but because it's a really
[ __ ] uncomfortable situation
in many cases you're asking someone who
can't give you a discount it's
completely out of your control there are
people around you and it it's just a
weird thing to ask so i wrote the
chapter i'm in sydney
and i thought i'm a [ __ ] hypocrite if
i don't do this so there's like a little
cafe near where i work i was like i'm
going to do it and there's no one there
so sweet no one's in the queue and as i
get there it got to the point where i
just didn't get served and then there's
two people behind me i was like [ __ ]
don't do it and i was like well it's
gonna feel very difficult right in the
next chapters of the book feeling like a
fraud
so i was like can i get a 10 discount on
my coffee please and she just looked at
me like
what and i was like i'm such an entitled
little prick right now this is how i
must see him
and she was like what do you mean i was
like can i get a 10 discount
and at this point i was like this is the
most uncomfortable i've been i was like
i would rather go out 5 000 people in a
crowd no
nothing pre-organized i'd rather do that
than do this situation right now and she
turned around behind and they had like a
stamp card where you get your 10th
coffee free and she was like but you buy
10 you can get 10 off
and then i walked away i'm in from that
and i realized why it was such a great
example because
it's not about the discount it's about
putting yourself in a situation that
makes you feel very uncomfortable and
then when you leave you realize
why did i create this fast why was i
sweating why did i have adrenaline why
did i have sweat patches from such a
simple interaction of being
uncomfortable
and i felt very accomplished and i
weren't like when i got back to writing
i felt invigorated i'm never going to
use that stamp card to me i'd rather not
worry about the card and pay for extra
for the coffee but i was like wow i was
like what else can i do and i only did
it as an exercise to help me with the
book writing process and i was like wow
i get it i get why people would tell
other people to do that because
people seem to think people are paying a
lot more attention to us than they
actually are mark manson he said as his
favorite quote on your podcast people
wouldn't care what other people thought
of them so much if they realized how
seldom they do
i had google seldom i didn't know what
it meant
and not yeah
um and i was like [ __ ] that's a really
good point and there's been studies on
this where people
turn up to class late they think
everyone's looking at them they are
students at the end if anyone came in
late the proportions were much lower and
even people that wear t-shirts with
embarrassing characters on it
they think that half the people they
interacted with would remember and the
percentages are much lower
we seem to think that we're in the
truman show in every single action we
take that the world cares about us but
they don't they don't even notice we're
there half the time the chances are the
people i was petrified of behind me
didn't even listen or they were too busy
they're on their phone checking tick
tock the person behind probably just
thought as a weirdo and never remembered
my face again maybe you inspired them
maybe maybe they're going to go do it
again so there are there are little
things like that or at least
if you have something in front of you
that is
really petrifying you is there some way
you could break that down into an
actionable step
say
you know if someone out there wants to
express their opinions on topic maybe
they're a physio maybe they're a pt
maybe they're an investment bank or a
mortgage broker they're petrified of
putting their opinion out there because
they're worried about what other
mortgage brokers or pts are going to
think they're worried about the people
that are never going to give them money
that's the [ __ ] craziest thing pt's
are petrified about what pt's think
about how many [ __ ] pts sat in your
console how many oh yeah i'd like to use
my pt
could they post something
because something is better than nothing
is there they don't have to be
controversial is there one step they can
take and if people can identify that one
small step if it's too big break it down
and
i just don't understand why
people can't set themselves that mental
exercise i think the most amazing thing
about the coffee example as well is the
fact that you actually got you found a
path to getting ten percent
and it's funny because so many times i
reflect on my own story just asking a
question was actually the catalyst it
was that was the inflection point in my
life where everything changed
and people don't have the confidence to
ask the question and it sounds like such
a trivial thing like when you was just
asking for temperature on coffee but for
me that was so profound that she she was
like what what but then if she turns
around and actually opens the door to 10
off you think about that in your life
generally you talk about it in the book
about asking for a pay rise or asking
for a promotion or asking for whatever
um i think if you zoom out on your life
and you are the type of person who
develops the habit of asking
your life will have a completely
different trajectory the further you
zoom out because i can tell you that the
pivotal moments in mind where i asked a
simple question
and it seemingly changed everything or
you know like you think about how things
compounded over time the compounding
moments were these moments of asking for
something which most people
would have
you know you talk about personality
types in here you say you know the need
to achieve or the need to avoid failure
i think a lot of that is is kind of
interlinked
with what we're saying here because i've
always had the
i feel like the need to achieve has
outweighed my my need to avoid failure
so i'm much more likely to ask for [ __ ]
from people especially when i started
out just email a guy would you invest in
my company the weird thing which i don't
think i ever talk about
is the first email i sent became my
first investor and i bet your
relationship with him saying no would
have been fine i had nothing to lose i
was shot lifting pizzas it was like
i was stealing pizzas to feed myself i'd
also emailed this guy and asked him for
10 grand and he said yeah
it's crazy you say that the it's this
point you have before about asking the
question i was
visiting in split they have these in
croatia they have these like waterfalls
and you go out like minivans and you go
and explore them usually we did got
weeks after we were like dying a little
bit let's go to a waterfall do something
wholesome there's a guy on a laptop at
the back of the minivan
and i was like what are you doing and he
was like i have an accountancy business
in miami i was like okay but what are
you doing here he's like i'm working i
was like what you're working on a laptop
from miami right now
now and i was like being inquisitive and
he goes can i recommend a book and he
recommended the book four hour by week
and i got home and i read through it and
there were some things that just didn't
apply to me at all but then the one
sentence summarized exactly every single
emotion i'd felt for the last year and
it said the opposite of happiness is
boredom
and within three weeks i flew to
australia one way that was my inception
moment a book recommendation from a
random guy in a minivan in croatia sent
me to do what is arguably no it is the
best single decision i made in my life
also
and
i do i look back now and i'm like whoa
the universe the butterfly effect if
yeah i had picked a different seat on
the minivan i don't know where i would
be today
the opposite of happiness is boredom
so sometimes when people experiencing
almost like a bit of malaise or they're
not experiencing happiness and it's full
emotion they think that and this is only
one spectrum of it
they're not sure of the emotion they're
experiencing
and for me i realized although i was
successful in the uk and pt and i was
bored
i wondered what this weird emotion was
why i wasn't feeling the same
motivation to go to work i wasn't
enjoying the same transactions and i
realized that
my growth had shunted without realizing
because i was comfortable i was earning
good money i was you know everything was
i was the highest paid pt in my gym it
was easy to just remain there were you
lacking a sense of purpose
probably
looking back now but i was meaningful
purpose like you've got a purpose you
know going to the gym a purpose but like
meaningful purpose where it really has
uh intrinsic
you know meaning to you you think it's a
worthwhile endeavor the way i feel now i
didn't think was possible when i was
younger so when i was 27 and made this
decision i didn't know that i could have
purpose in that respect i was very happy
just being a pt in the gym but i never
realized i'd always up until this point
of i'd gone 26 out of 27 years
never earning enough money to really get
by you know i'd never really succeeded
in business 27 this is the first time
i've actually accomplished anything all
my jobs and relationships before i've
just been failed at at 27 years old i'd
done nothing remarkable with my life
whatsoever
rugby career average grades average job
performance is average at 27 i was
actually excelling in something for the
first time in my life so being bored was
a very strange emotion i couldn't
decipher it's like what is this feeling
because i'd never succeeded at anything
really i didn't think it was possible to
be successful and board at the same time
and then
flying to australia i was never bored
again and i haven't been since i think a
lot of people are successful on board
you know what i mean successful in the
context of someone else of the social
definition of success right you're not
truly successful i think if you're bored
but you are in the eyes of maybe your
parents that wanted you to be a doctor
and now look at you smashing it as a
doctor but you you know but you're
you're bored
another tough thing to take into account
was the fact i was servicing about seven
hours a day of pt which is like seven
one to one meetings and i mean
it's quite hard because at least when we
do a podcast now if it's two hours we
can go hard for these two hours because
we know there are going to be millions
of hours listening to you but for me
that one hour i spend with a client it's
just one person yeah if we were to
record this and only one person would
listen to it you'd be like i'm not sure
this is really cost efficient so those
seven hours a day
although i had a purpose in those lives
it almost got to the point where i was
like i could be helping more and that's
why i enjoyed doing social media
although i didn't pay off for the first
four years and that's the purpose piece
though that's the that's it would be
even more meaningful and worthwhile for
you to do
to do more and people say this now they
go would you pt someone for two thousand
pounds an hour like i was tempted
but
that one hour i could spend making one
video that could i get that all the time
people people say to me you should be
like a life coach where you should um do
coaching sessions
and i'm like yeah but i get to do
coaching sessions on here by bringing on
like you know people like you and simon
sinek and whoever i bring on this is the
coaching session and millions can listen
versus one on one and it almost seems
like a bit of a bit of a waste not no
disrespect to my clients before they
were the people that enabled me to sit
here right now and i'll be forever
grateful for them but it did get to the
point where i was like
i almost take more happiness from
helping thousands than i would want and
the financial implications are obviously
very different but
it's amazing to see a video where so
many people the video might take me 15
minutes to make an edit and put out i
still i'm i do my own editing it's
probably the happiest moment of some of
my days i love the creation phase
like i've had an idea it's been born
i've recorded it run to my room i'm
editing it getting all perfect then i
put it out and i check the next day and
i'm like i can't comprehend the amount
of people that might have benefited and
especially when something gets a lot of
views and i'm sure let's say you put
this podcast out i'm not sure i did this
the other day i was watching england
play rugby i was in a stadium with 50
000 people
and i was like there's a lot of people
here and if someone asked me to go into
the middle
and be like james here's a microphone
chat [ __ ] i like that's a lot of people
my story reviews were a quarter of a
million the same day and i was like
how is this real how is this real and
when you think about the amount of
people you can talk to i can't
comprehend it
what would you say to those people that
are currently bored in their lives
sometimes my biggest fear is setting my
sights on a mountain where i could reach
the summit
and i think some people haven't realized
they've reached the summit and it's very
important that you get to that point and
you set a new height to accomplish
so
again i always talk about jiu-jitsu but
for me that is something that will never
be finished
i will never
conquer that and it doesn't have to be
martial arts for people but there should
be something that you move away from
your business because someone can take
away your business someone can take away
your social media someone can take away
everything but they can't take away that
and having something where you know
you'll never master it i think i know
i've discovered that i'll never be bored
and i love that because if i break my
leg tomorrow training i can teach and if
i can't teach i can study and if i can
study i can pass on the information to
other people i feel like stagnation
is like my biggest fear
and i think a lot of people just haven't
realized that they're there so they just
need to set their sights on something
anything no it's interesting it's
interesting that i everything you've
said resonates a lot there because i
realized at some point maybe when i
completed the first set of goals i had
at 18 that the only goals worth having
in this phase in the next chapter of my
life were those that are incompletable
so in like every facet of my life the
the best goals i have the most
the most intrinsically fulfilling are
those that i know i can't complete so i
posted on my instagram the other day
about the gym
every year i wanted to get a six-pack
for summer that was the goal
you know it would maybe last four months
and then i'd fail at some point my goal
became consistency something that i
could never really complete it's
something that i can you know achieve
every day but a goal that can't be
completed and it's the same with this
podcast the reason it's so enjoyable
is because there is absolutely no end
there's no conceivable end in sight it's
the journey itself and it's the it's the
the process that i think is going to be
rewarding and then i tried to change all
my businesses at one point when i
started reading about simon sinek and
infinite games and finite games so i
said what would i have to do to create a
business from top to bottom that was
designed to
to not have these goals of like let's be
number one or let's make 100 million but
was infinite and it completely changes
everything and then it has a really
impact and strange impact on how you
treat people as team members
so you start designing the organization
to be sustainable in every way that is
where i'm at in my life now it's trying
to fill my life with these incompletable
goals because completed goals let me
down
you know i said about the ansi climax
seeking inspiration from people that
have done it from our last conversation
i didn't realize how much our
conversation had impacted me until i got
home and i was like
i'm not producing a good level podcast i
was like i need to get proper
microphones i need to invest in better
cameras i need to do a better job
editing
and then your social strategy as well
just every facet of it i was like i was
inspired by you doing better than me and
that was something that i'd three months
later i went [ __ ] sitting down with you
i was like that really like rubbed
shoulders in a way that benefited me and
i was like it's one of the first times
i've really felt the impact of
what even just sitting and talking
someone can do for your inhabits and i
found it such a shame that some people
won't be inspired by other people's
success i feel like it's a shame that so
many people see success and see as a
reason to be bitter
and
yeah for me it was it was great i left
feeling for a start
i think you forced a lot of people that
didn't like me to listen
they i know a lot of people would have
gone why the [ __ ] yeah stephen sat down
with him yeah yeah and they've gone pro
listen to and i got a lot of people
messaging me going i thought you're a
dick we have a closing tradition on this
podcast as you know of your question
funnily enough has been left by the
liver king
oh snap
i didn't think about that when you said
he was the last one on i was like oh
that's really cool i was like i kind of
would have liked to have met him and
just to
be in his aura not because i'm a fanboy
but like i always look at him and i'm
like i want to know how he smells
you know he smells bad but and i'm only
saying that because he said it so he
walked in and said by the way i smell
bad because i don't use any deodorant
but um i don't actually usually tell
people who's written the question but
i'll make an exception today
um
what is the hardest
why am i
nervous that's a question i feel like is
you know when you're an interview like
ready to get a job you're like the last
question if you want to win
what is the hardest thing you've ever
done in life
your right of passage
oh i gotta try and answer this that
sounds like a [ __ ]
right of passage hardest thing i've ever
done
see all the things that come to mind
like jokes i can make
like putting up with durian's
disorganization or something you know
but i've got to think about serious
answer
he talked a lot about this concept of
your rite of passage so his hardest
moments in life he sees them all as a
right of passage for getting somewhere
else
the only real thing that i would say has
been
hard or even noteworthy would be the
ability
to fall in love with repetition of dull
tasks
it sounds like a really weird thing to
say it's the only really painful thing
i've ever done in my life really where
there are things you need to do every
day consistently for years without
any form of
you know instant gratification and
evidently not enough people have that
ability
and there have been so many days of not
wanted to do anything
but you do it anyway and you kind of
fall in love with these
very small minute repetitions and it's
the only thing that i've ever really
found hard in my life and it definitely
sounds like i'm coming from a point of
privilege i feel like i've done a
disservice you probably expected a lot
more battle-hardened people i wish i
could say it was a tour of afghanistan
or working in a award during kovid or
you know saving someone's life but
i probably haven't i've probably done
liver king dirty a little bit there
those small disciplines you're talking
about though those small things where
you know we all have them every day it
could be as small as just going going to
the gym avoiding eating something that's
tempting whatever those small
disciplines end up defining us over the
long term as one of my favorite books
the slight edge um describes
what is driving those small disciplines
on a day-to-day basis why are you doing
those small those small repetitions if
there is no instant gratification i
think
one thing it's difficult to credit
yourself with stuff but i've always been
very good at seeing long-term benefit
of short-term actions
and
you know
for me even little things i've got a
strange insight in life where so many
people are focused on doing things now
for a better life later on when i'm
completely inverted i'm so focused on
having a good life now for my my life
isn't that stressful everyone's like oh
you should buy a house or buy 10 houses
and for me i'm like it'd be good
financially but it's stressful
and for me i know if i turn up into
these little things every day that
future life
future relationships future family can
benefit from it something that my
parents have definitely done
my dad commuted into london for 50 years
the same business every day it's about
an hour and 25 minutes from where we
live there and back every day he never
pulled sick days he was never lazy my
mum was also incredibly consistent with
the upbringing of me and my sister and i
look back at the amount of sacrifice
that they made short little things like
putting up with my behavior or my dad
going to work on a train every day and i
think
he only really ever did these things
not for himself but for people that
didn't exist yet
almost like confidence is predicting
success in the future we can create
success in the future by doing these
small things so i think it's definitely
stemmed from that where
it's not so much about me because i'm
happy now but if i keep doing these
things i can create happiness for people
further down the line we talk about
privilege as well like we could talk
about
any form of privilege whether it's
racial economic whatever
we need to take some ownership that the
reason someone like me can take an
experienced privilege now is the fact
that people before me were long-sighted
with their goals and ambitions and the
people before them were as well
my parents made very smart decisions for
me to be able to be able to go to
australia at 27. that was a privilege
for some people they have family members
that
rely on them they have
professional if you're a police officer
you work in a hospital you don't have
the luxury of just leaving your precinct
to go on a jolly to the other side of
the world as the pt i did
so
yeah i think i do the small things now
so that in the long term in the future
someone else can reap the benefits that
i did of them i have to say well done
and thank you for writing a book on this
topic because it is a topic that so many
people i think
i think i'm right in saying that
confidence is the single biggest topic
that i'm peppered with in terms of
questions people are trying to figure it
out because it is this great inhibitor
of all they believe they can be it is a
great inhibitor of so much happiness and
health and fulfillment and all of those
things so when i
it was also one of the things that i i
did consider writing a book about one
day but after reading your book
and and understanding how nuanced and
truthful and honest and
appreciative of both sides of the coin
it is i don't feel like i ever have to
write a book of confidence again because
i think you really covered it so well
done thank you people are going to love
this book for sure thank you very much
and you know that as well i think
because i i'm
you know i asked that first question at
the start about why you wrote about
confidence assuming it was because of
the because the fact you also get
peppered in various ways even even as
you say with those pain points if
they're not saying it directly at the
heart of it they are trying to figure
out how to
how to to achieve their goals
ultimately by this word that they
believe is is confidence so well done
thank you thanks for coming back here i
love these conversations i do them over
and over again just because half the
time i'm doing it just to try and
develop my own thinking um and it's also
a huge honor that you even listened to
this podcast i find that really awesome
because you're
incredibly smart person you're
incredibly nice guy and um those are the
kind of people that uh
i love
um spending time with so thanks james
hope to see you again soon if you'll
ever come back on of course and i hope
this book tour goes incredibly well
thank you very much
i am so excited to announce our new
sponsor for this podcast and that is
blue jeans by verizon for any of you
that aren't already familiar with
bluejeans they are a video conferencing
and collaboration tool who offer an
immersive communication experience that
drives pretty unparalleled employee and
customer engagement experiences me and
all of my teams across all of my
portfolio companies switched over to
blue jeans a couple of months ago and we
have not looked back the best thing for
us has been the totally frictionless
experience no glitching no sound issues
no delays or any of those things that
usually make virtual meetings really
really frustrating we use blue jeans
anywhere on any device at any time and
it's perfect for my small businesses
that just have 10 or 20 people to some
of my bigger businesses that have
hundreds of people i'm a big fan as you
can probably tell so i've been quite
excited for for some time to announce
this partnership and in the coming weeks
i'll explain the features and really why
it's perfect for you if you haven't
considered using or switching over to
blue jeans yet but if you can't wait
head over to bluejeans.com to learn more
honestly it's been one of the real sort
of game changers in my business
quick one it's so crazy that in the last
couple of months i've had so many people
tag me on instagram even on telegram and
in my twitter dms
in a picture of them starting their heel
journey and it's one of the most
amazing things in my life that i get to
do a podcast which of course needs money
to to fuel and i have a sponsor like you
who i genuinely believe is going to help
every single person
who starts their heel journey change
their life because this podcast the
central intention of this podcast is to
help people live better lives and we get
to sit here and i get to promote to you
a product which has not only helped me
change my life but it's going to help
millions of people and is helping
millions of people live a nutritionally
complete life it's so it's such an
incredible product and for me the reason
why it's incredible is because it gives
me my protein it gives me my vitamins
minerals it's plant-based it's low in
sugar gluten-free it does all of that in
a small drink that tastes good there are
other products there's foods there's the
hot and savory collection many other
things but for me this ready to drink is
the absolute saviour of my diet
throughout the week where i'm moving at
such pace
look i don't want to labor the point but
if you haven't tried you'll give it a
try and if you do
tag me instagram wherever you try it
give me a tag
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you